uh reached out to Andrew Santino I don't
know how many times too many every time
I asked can you do my podcast got to a
point where I was so frustrated that I
lashed out in the most humiliating way I
was typing so fast and I wrote eat
s-h-i-y I misspelled it and just and it
was already sent and I was about to go
you bro and I'm like no no he's mad
I could talk it had nothing to do with
with you no no I've been a comic for 20
years like I get it by now when I fight
with Bobby when I get into it with any
friends in our world
I know right away it's some other
it's a relationship you're tired it's
family dude it's always everything
else Burr one time and I had a little
thing if something happened and a couple
days later he texted me and was like I'm
sorry man I don't know why I said that I
don't know why this went this way and
explained to me like what was going on I
knew some other was up and he was
like that had nothing to do with you but
for some reason you were in the line of
fire and you got clipped